hey guys it's max we just got in apple's
new magsafe accessories and today
we're gonna find out and tell you who
should actually spend
50 on this new iphone 12 magsafe case
and we're going to be testing it out and
comparing it to the previous case
and how well your max safe charger will
work if you don't spend 50 bucks and you
go for one of the suggested alternatives
that we'll be talking about now i bought
and i will be using
this new transparent case and that is
going to show off that really bright
blue new color on the iphone 12 that we
have coming in
in just two days now so make sure you
guys are subscribed
but with this clear case specifically
there are two
issues that we will be covering but
first off let's take a look
and i'll give you guys my first
impression so right away
we see this little band where the
magnets are held and this little
aligning magnet
and it's interesting that i can feel it
on the back here so there
is actually a little cut out for the
magnets but it's not completely flush
before i test out how strong the
magnetic connection is i want to point
out a couple differences
compared to last year first off the
camera bump
is slightly larger we stack them up like
this is not a significant difference but
you could tell
that apple did increase the camera bump
one of the lenses got larger there
and another interesting difference is
these buttons as i'm pressing this
little side button
the new one the new 50 one actually is a
lot softer so you have soft plastic
inside
the old one had that as well but it was
much more firm and it made it harder to
turn on the phone and adjust your
volumes now the main reason why i bought
apple's clear case is because it stays
clear compared to some of the third
parties which we'll talk about in just a
bit
now another interesting difference is
that the old version wrapped around the
phone
way more and since apple's cases are
really hard
plastic i actually got a crack in it
shortly after i
bought it which was a big disappointment
when you're spending 40 bucks
now if you're spending 50 bucks it's
interesting that the case itself is way
more rigid it could be because of the
boxy design
but the edges do not wrap around
anywhere near as much as the old one
there's still a tiny bit of a lip
but i'm guessing because of magsafe we
don't need such a strong
lip there and because of that this new
one is going to be
much less likely to crack than the old
ones the last thing i have to point out
before we test out magsafe and if
magsafe will work
through a non-magsafe case is that the
bottom of the new case is still cut out
on the clear version to allow the phone
to go any easier
compared to all the silicon options that
are now completely sealed off
for the first time and some of the much
cheaper third-party clear cases that
also will give you better protection on
the bottom
let's grab our magsafe charger now and
we'll test it out
and by the way vadim has a video coming
for apple's master plan with magsafe
coming out tomorrow so make sure you
guys have those notifications enabled
and right away that was a very solid
connection
oddly very satisfying how it aligns
let's see if it
works just as well yep no issues because
we don't have any
uh extra magnets in the cable to line up
here that's for other accessories see if
i get it halfway on
it's still not going on there you go so
you have to get it somewhat close
but any quick little connection like
that if you're trying to attach it
quickly
if you get it close enough it'll just
move over to the side which is nice
i'm a big fan of wireless charging i
wireless charge most of the time but one
issue is
at my nightstand i can't charge my phone
and use it at the same time so
if i want to use it in bed and my
battery is low i have to go find a
different charger so this thing is going
to solve that issue
because as you guys can see we can
actually spin this around the cable
anyway so if i'm holding it this way
i have the cable coming off on the left
hand side i can use the phone without an
issue
this way bam you spin it align exactly
how you want
you can charge and now charge very fast
at 15 watts
and still you know be able to use your
phone which is great
this is the main reason why you're gonna
be spending 50 bucks on an apple case
is for this magsafe convenience whereas
last year
people bought them just because they
wanted an apple branded case
now what i'm curious about is how well
does this magsafe
band same ones in the iphone work if you
buy a regular case
so since we still have a few days until
our iphones get here
let's simulate this i'm going to put
this smaller iphone now it's smaller
into the previous iphone 11 case and
let's see how strong our connection is
so the connection is still there it
still snaps into place
but that is actually surprisingly much
weaker and it is flush against each
other so
there's a chance that the iphone might
have stronger magnets than this i don't
think so personally because in mkbhd's
video his wallet
did not stay on that well competing
anywhere near
as good as this magsafe charger is
staying on
so yeah through that you just pull the
cable a little bit
and it starts coming off to be honest i
wasn't expecting it to be this week
through a relatively
thin case let's do a hanging test there
interesting and i know there's a lot of
thicker third party cases on the market
i'm guessing that if you buy one of
those third-party cases
that are thicker when most are than this
iphone case you're gonna have a harder
time
using magsafe and not having it
disconnect look at this i just push a
little bit and it starts coming off
and let's check out how it is without
your thin case just with the magsafe now
that is a solid connection so now i
understand why apple is putting these
in all their cases uh because that is a
much much better connection
and this is the reason why you're gonna
be buying a magsafe branded case
now there are some third-party
alternatives that also feature magsafe
but i really wonder how strong that is
based on mac rumors video
the otterbox case had a sticker like a
magnetic sticker on the
inside and that's a thicker case as well
so that makes me wonder
how strong is that connection is it
anywhere near as good as this one and i
have to be honest
even though it's weird to say magsafe is
one of the most exciting things
about the iphone 12 not only how
convenient it is
and i don't think a lot of people
realize how small this is when they look
online
here's a mophie one and this is a very
slim and small
wireless charger this came out when
wireless charging came out apple is
selling this one right now
look at the difference here in size and
thickness
the new mac safe one is tiny it's not
gonna take up a lot of space it looks
clean
and then look at the difference in
thinness and then with the mophie i
guess
maybe you could hold it in your hand and
do that i mean i've never done that
before but potentially you could
but with magsafe it's going to be much
more convenient and i have to ask you
guys
this how often do you put your phone on
a wireless charger
and then it doesn't charge because it's
not lined up perfectly for the coil
for me that's probably about two maybe
three times a month
either the battery and the phone wasn't
perfectly lined so the battery
didn't charge up completely had a very
low charge not efficient
or i wake up on my phone is dead because
it was a little too far
off and now that is not going to be an
issue
and now let's answer the main question
who should spend 50 bucks on this case
and who should buy one of our suggested
alternatives that are linked in the
video
description if you're somebody first off
that's buying this magsafe charger i
would highly
highly recommend buying an apple branded
mac safe case or one of the alternatives
if they're anywhere near as good
with this magnetic connection we just
saw that through this thin case
the max safe connection was much much
weaker and it doesn't hold on it doesn't
snap into place anywhere near as well
now also with that if you're somebody
that's going to want to use other
accessories
that are going to be using magsafe such
as pop sockets
car mounts other chargers in the future
you might get gimbals
selfie sticks if you're still using one
of those magsafe is going to be
very useful for useful for a ton of
accessories so
if you're buying a case you're going to
keep it for a year or more you want to
keep that in mind
even if you don't want wireless charging
there's going to be a lot of other
accessories
and with that which of you should save
your money and buy one of our suggested
cases
for between 10 to 20 dollars well first
off
if you don't use wireless charging at
all you have no interest in that you're
not somebody that uses different
accessories
you're just basically keep your phone in
your pocket or in your purse
and you charge once at night then you
might not need
mac safe and then with that as well if
you're somebody that does want a clear
case
but you don't like this kind of a look
over here and you're not going to use
magsafe
or that's not that important to you and
you want extra protection on the bottom
of this clear case there's some good
alternatives that are
thin and they're clear and they give you
extra protection
as well and there's one extra reason and
not to buy apple's mag safe case
especially the clear one and that is
scratches
this case right here is a year old and
we have a ton of scratches on it it's
very ugly
and that's because apple uses this hard
clear plastic
it's very slick and it's very prone to
scratches where a lot of the
alternatives
the clear ones especially that cover up
the bottom they're using a more
rubbery material that you get a little
bit more grip from
and it's much more scratch resistant all
right guys let us know
are you willing to spend 50 for apple's
new cases
now that they have mac safe built in
where maybe
you weren't willing to spend 40 bucks
before
i want to hear your opinions down in the
comments section below
make sure you guys have those
notifications enabled because you guys
don't want to miss out our future videos
we have apple's master plan for mac safe
coming out and our hands-on comparisons
in just two days a lot of great content
thank you guys for watching click that
circle above to subscribe and if you
want to check out the buyer's guide
on which iphone you should buy it is
right over there this one max and i'll
see you in the next video